Guten morgen linus.
Guten morgen tim.
Schon gehört der ber macht auf.
Eine eine ära geht zu ende eine ära der witze was machen wir was sollen wir danach der witze machen keine brexit wird zu mehr keine witze mehr.
Keine angst brexit hält noch eine weile.
Aux
Buch netzpolitik nummer dreihundertneunundzwanzig.
Heute ist ja sogar der brexit tag ne.
Einunddreißigster erster zwanzig zwanzig jetzt geht die scheiße eigentlich erst richtig los jetzt wird's lustig.
Habe ich das habe ich das jetzt heute morgen richtig gesehen auf twitter dass dass da irgendwelche typen mit dem dudelsack und mit der union jack irgendwie dann durch brüssel marschiert sind um nicht zu zelebrieren ich weiß nicht.
Ich habe den scheiß also ich weiß nicht ganz genau in brüssel war ja im wesentlichen wurde er eher so nochmal ein bisschen bejubelt so.
Aber natürlich haben sich hier diese ganzen schergen und honks rund um farage nochmal ordentlich daneben benommen aber das ist halt auch so randnotizen lustig wird's halt jetzt.
Den auswirkungen weil sie träumen ja jetzt irgendwie immer noch davon die eu unter druck zu setzen,
dass sie sich da erheblich behoben haben insbesondere mit so maßnahmen wie,
durch gesetzliche änderungen auch auszuschließen dass es nochmal zu einer verlängerung kommt was natürlich für ihre verhandlungsposition tödlich ist und ich glaube die eu ist halt jetzt in dem modus,
ihr wolltet raus jetzt seid ihr raus jetzt.
Wenn ihr fühlen wie es ist sich außerhalb der europäischen union zu befinden und viel spaß mit euern.
Träumen von zugang zum single market wenn ihr den in irgendeiner form behalten wird dann dann wird es teuer aber so also richtig so richtig teuer.
Ich glaube die werden die daumenschrauben jetzt erheblich anziehen und der lehrerin stehen die eu hat er es halt riesig weil das wird dann zum ende des jahres nochmal richtig sportlich werden.
So mit allem was halt der hard brexit so mit sich bringt versorgungsengpässe.
Corona virus.
Ja gut bleibt ja nun nicht an gesetzesgrundlagen stehen aber.
Das das das wird das wird sehr interessant sein und ich glaube dass die der verlierer sein wird der große große verlierer.
Hoffentlich weil dann sind wir die gewinner.
Na gut wir können halt im wesentlichen eigentlich nur schadensbegrenzung betreiben.
Verloren wir es in der rest der eu haben.
Das alte europa.
Ja ich meine wir haben auch verloren mit diesem brexit nur eben nicht so viel wie okay.
Weißt du weißt du wie viel platz in der europäischen union jetzt frei wird.
Ja ein gib.
Der wird spekuliert aber auch schon seit einem jahr.
Ach echt ich dachte der wäre von charlie.
Ich glaube ich habe schon alle brexit witze gehört aber wie gesagt keine angst da kommen noch neue dazu das wird jetzt erst richtig lustig weil jetzt stehen sie halt mit runter gelassener hose da,
und das nicht schön was wir dann sehen.
Hallo.
Feedback hat ja wir haben immer viel feedback und
eine eines finde ich deshalb wichtig weil es zur sendung zur letzten sendung dreihundertachtundzwanzig thema passwort herausgabe und so sich betrifft und ein aspekt
betrifft den wir da gar nicht so richtig aufgegriffen haben.
Zwar kommentiert lukas wurde zwar in dieser sendung nur angerissen aber noch ein gedanke zur passwort weitergabe an behörden.
Es ist ja auch beim trojaner ein problem aber hier eigentlich noch mehr wie ich finde wie ist das denn mit der beweiskraft,
wenn behörden sich komplett authentifiziere ist es unterscheidbar wer gerade die aktuelle session führt.
Wäre ein leichtes belastende e-mails nachrichten whatever einfach mal zu verfassen,
stichwort beweise unterschrieben beim trojaner ist der zugriff ein anderer wird einfach nur eine gültige session gefordert müsste,
doch die gerichtsbarkeit s extrem angezweifelt werden können selbst wenn in der behörde ein lok zwang besteht allein die tatsache dass zugesichert ist dass das passwort an dritte gegeben wurde schränkt das doch ein,
also es geht dabei darum wenn jetzt also eine eine strafverfolgungsbehörde ein passwort anfordert dann hat sie ja damit die möglichkeit
auf diesen sagen wir mal e-mail-account zuzugreifen könnte also sachen löschen könnte sachen schreiben könnte per app irgendwelche e-mails auf die server schieben,
ähnliches ist bei forensischen untersuchungen grundsätzlich der fall und bei einem beinahe beim staatstrojaner
auch der fall tatsächlich war genau dieser aspekt ja der grund warum der digitalstadt janer.
Nicht mehr eingesetzt werden durften nach der analyse des c weil er es ermöglichte durch updates und nach ladefunktion,
letztendlich sabitri wäre module hochzuladen die gesetzliche anforderungen ist aber dass das ding nur lesen kann gibt also quasi immer,
diese verschiedenen zugriffe die jetzt sagen wir mal auf ganz high level unterschieden werden lesen schreiben ausführen,
betrifft also gewissermaßen auch diese ziele vertraulichkeit integrität verfügbarkeit verfügbarkeit so ein bisschen,
ausgelassen aber kann ich das ist kann ich mir das nur angucken oder kann ich das auch verändern ist bei beiden der fall und deswegen weil er sich jetzt technisch nicht ausschließen lässt und da kommentiert auch mutti waters eben dazu,
im zweifel lief es darauf hinaus dass die technischen anforderungen an eine gerichtsfest in anführungszeichen technische umsetzung nach und nach durch die rechtsprechung konkretisiert würden
dazu könnte neben dem detaillierten losging beziehungsweise nur lesezugriff für behörden gegebenenfalls,
kombiniert mit einer gesetzlichen verpflichtung der dienst an bieter diese zu einem gewissen grad zum beispiel durch mehrfach verschlüsselung,
technisch zu erzwingen also beispielsweise könnte man ja einen also die lösung für sowas ist dann ja okay wir bauen ein clint ja der kann dem fehlt die funktion.
Irgendwas zu aktualisieren.
Irgendwas hochzuladen oder so der kann nur sachen runterladen
der kann nur das postfach einmal dampfen und dann würden die im zweifelsfall sagen ja stimmt weil der forensiker der das der dieses die e-mail
extraktion jetzt durchgeführt hat der hat hier nämlich eidesstattlich versichert dass er nur dieses programm genutzt hat und es gibt ein video davon oder so
du hast aber natürlich recht lukas dass es eben nicht ausgeschlossen werden kann und das ist ein wichtiger aspekt ist warum man genau diese passwort herausgabe,
überhaupt nicht erst gesetzlich verankern sollte weil das eben von oben bis unten nach problemen riecht und unnötig ist wenn wir uns überlegen dass es ja diese ganzen möglichkeiten zum zugriff ohnehin gibt.
Ja also völlig verrückte idee insofern danke für den für die hinweise an lukas und,
waters.
Ja sehr schön danke danke.
Auch ein sehr sehr schöner gedanke klassisch klassiker wie wie heißt denn catch me too auf deutsch trick siebzehn oder wie würde man das am ehesten übersetzen.
Da ist so ein gefangen in ähm tja ich weiß auch nicht eine paradoxe paradoxe situationen zwickmühle.
Zeckenmühle.
Wo man nicht rauskommt.
Kann man das nicht irgendwie hier mal mit einem klugen internet übersetzen.
Naja zwickmühle ist doch eine ganz gute übersetzung also zwickmühle ist ja aus dem spiel mühle wurde ich sozusagen jeder jeder zug.
Genau was auch immer du machst wirst du wirst jetzt verlieren ne.
So ein sehr interessantes gerichtsverfahren vor dem bundesverwaltungsgericht leipzig zum anfang dieser woche.
Bei uns mehrfach in der sendung behandelt wurde das verbot der,
die internetseite links unten in die media.
Punkt org glaube ich eine webseite die seit ein paar jahren als subdomain von indimedia betrieben wurde vielleicht muss man erstmal erklären was in die media ist,
in die media ist eine open posting webseite also so eine,
bürgerinnen journalismus idee ja die quasi sagten ich glaube das ursprüngliche motto war down the media media,
um quasi zu sagen bei uns ist es so du kannst dort deine artikel schreiben du kannst über dinge berichten und dass wir dann,
veröffentlicht um eine zur gründung von indimedia noch,
äußerst revolutionäre idee weil es zu diesen zeiten glaube ich twitter noch gar nicht gab facebook noch gar nicht gab oder vielleicht gab es die aber die wollen noch nicht so verwendet ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau wann in die media gegründet,
ist aber mehr als zehn jahre her.
Das ist auf jeden fall älter als dieser ganze graben.
Du kannst du kannst ja mal kurz schauen wenn also ein vor,
vor mehr als einem jahrzehnt sicherlich enorm revolutionärer gedanke der eben auch zum ersten mal anfing diese potenziale,
der des internets als medium für alle auch so gezielt ausnutzen zu wollen gezielt hebeln zu wollen mit einem mit einem politischen anspruch dahinter.
Zweitausendeins ist in die media gestartet fünf jahre vor twitter.
Fünf jahre vor twitter und facebook gast facebook zweitausendeins schon.
Ja aber nicht in irgendeiner form sichtbar also ich glaube das ging da.
Und ja und und das hatte dann hatte er es der politische anspruch von facebook hat sich ja dann erst mit der monetarisieren.
Facebook sogar auch erst zweitausendvier aber das war ja dann auch erstmal nur zuckerbergs private tinder ja also.
Okay also tatsächlich also vor neunzehn jahren ungefähr,
die gründung von indimedia bürgerinnen journalismus und dann ging das relativ schnell weiter dass es dann eben de in die media dot org gab also das deutsche in die media.
Man muss ja auch sagen das ist ja auch nicht ohne tradition in in deutschland also es gab ja schon in den achtziger jahren so,
tabus mailbox netze und mir gerade der name entfallen also auch da gab's ja dann sozusagen auch schon die erste nutzung von mailbox netzen um alternative informationen,
aus jugoslawien zu erholen ballon adam für boot war da sehr aktiv.
Da gab's auch einen kongress vortrag zu.
Oder garantie mir jetzt gerade so,
kurzfristig gerade nicht die ganzen stichworte parat aber das ist sozusagen etwas was jetzt in der deutschen netz affin szene schon lange kolportiert worden ist und durch die neunziger jahre zamir hieß dieses netzwerk,
ja also.
Und da hatten wir beim fünfunddreißig glaube ich ein vortrag zu verlinken wir ihnen schon was ich suche den raum.
Genau also das ist sozusagen etwas was was sagen wir mal in der netzpolitische.
Orientierten szene schon lange eine grundidee war eigene mediale strukturen zu schaffen um eben eine gegen öffentlichkeit auch zu ermöglichen oder es in die media in gewisser hinsicht dann,
verhältnismäßig früh vergleich zu diesem großen neuen sichtbaren netzwerken da gewesen aber steht eigentlich in gewisser hinsicht in der tradition hat dann eben einfach das web genutzt,
das ist das was in die media war.
Gibt's immer noch.
Ist entschuldigung ja.
Jetzt hat indimedia eben auch sich als als bewegung als konzept eben auch subdomain vergeben da gab es die deutsche in den media gründete sich und,
dann wurden natürlich auch irgendwelche formen der moderation.
Eingeführt und wie das so ist bei progressiven gruppierungen dann zeigt man sich darüber wie viel man jetzt moderieren darf und wieviel nicht und dann gab es irgendwann die ausgründung
oder dass das weitere projekt links unten punkt in die media die den name glaube ich primär aus daher kommt dass das,
betreiber team sich links unten auf der deutschlandkarte gesehen hat aber weil es natürlich auch ganz cool klingt so ne wir sind links unten hat sich dann,
etabliert als eine,
als eine plattform in der der gedanke des open posting noch sehr viel radikaler verfolgt wird also die noch höhere schranken für sich selber auferlegt hatten um dort,
für das entfernen oder moderieren von beiträgen also eine radikale meinungsfreiheit und äußerung freiheitsgedanke als der in den anderen plattformen galt das wird ja dann auch immer unter den,
betreiberinnen irgendwie ausgehandelt so.
Über die jahre entwickelte links unten sich dann zu einer plattform auf der unter anderem auch,
dox xing von irgendwelchen,
rechtsradikalen bekennerschreiben nach irgendwelchen aktionen oder auch ankündigungen aufrufe zur aktion,
sich sammeln so das war nicht der hauptinhalt dieser webseite aber das kann man ja immer von zwei seiten betrachten
wenn du irgendwas auf links unten in die media dir angeschaut hast dann war das mit relativ geringer wahrscheinlichkeit
ein ein ein aufruf zur gewalt oder ein bekennerschreiben aber wenn du dir im internet ein bekennerschreiben einer radikalen linken gruppierungen angeschaut hat dann war das mit relativ großer wahrscheinlichkeit auf links unten veröffentlicht worden
also immer die beiden seiten was hier auch die mengen.
Angeht so jetzt begab es sich dann zweitausendsiebzehn nach dem
g zwanzig-gipfel in deutschland das ja eine relativ ausführliche debatte in deutschland geführt wurde über gewalt bereite linksradikale gruppierungen.
Wir haben auch hier damals darüber gesprochen wie hieß denn der titel,
wir hatten da ich weiß dass wir auch noch einen ganz unterhaltsamen titel hatten wir hatten.
Zu den vorgängen leipzig oder wenn man's jetzt geht zwanzig.
Da hatten wir auch ein sendungsmast und haben uns da so ein bisschen darüber unterhalten wie auch quasi hier durch das polizeiliche vorgehen,
sagen wir mal in richtung der
gewaltbereiten auseinandersetzungen gelenkt wurde na wir klassisch ist ja hier diese der verlauf der welcome to hell demo die da unten an der hafenstraße startete und quasi zu zu zu dem zeitraum als ich die,
demonstrierenden dort versammelt haben standen denen schon die wasserwerfer entgegen ihrer lauf route entgegen unseren wasserwerfer kann bekanntlich relativ schwer rückwärts fahren und ist dann eben auch vorwärts gefahren wo es eben zu
in einer ganzen reihe an polizeigewalt kam aber eben auch zu einer ganzen reihe an.
Sachbeschädigungen und randale von seiten einiger weniger demonstrierenden.
Logbuch netzpolitik zweihundertfünfundzwanzig dringende bitte.
Ach ja genau zweihundertfünfundzwanzig dringende bitte genau weil die polizei hat die dringende bitte hatte jetzt zu gehen ok also es ist nach dem g zwanzig es wird.
Im übrigen und das kann man glaube ich an der stelle auch mal sagen denke ich eine der,
meist gehörten folgen von logbuch netzpolitik ich bestätige das gerade nochmal aber die ging ganz gut die ging ganz gut weg und das auch aus gutem grund die war nämlich toll.
Was nicht an uns liegt sondern in unserem gast.
Genau und john f nebel.
So dieses diese.
In diesem zeitraum in diesem es gab damals dann in der nachbereitung gab es diese webseite g zwanzig
doku info oder dort oder sowas die die polizeigewalt,
die da demonstrierende erfahren haben dokumentiert hat es gab gleichzeitig eine ganze reihe an irgendwelchen anzeigen gegen menschen die sich an diesen protesten beteiligt haben
und linke gewalt war das große thema ist es ja auch heute noch wir wissen die linke gewalt ist sehr sehr problematisch.
Vor allem für die cdu wenn gleich sie selber eher von rechten ermordet werden aber das war eben das thema
zwanzigsiebzehn innenminister war wenn ich mich recht entsinne zu dem zeitpunkt noch thomas de maizière und der hat dann gesagt okay wir werden jetzt.
Diese webseite links unten.
Punkt in die media verbieten und das ist natürlich schwierig wie wie verbietest du jetzt so eine webseite und was der der rechtliche hebel den sie genutzt haben ist sie haben,
diejenigen die diese webseite betrieben haben zu einem verein.
Als ein verein benannt und haben diesen verein verboten und damit auch die tätigkeit des vereines nämlich dieses medium zu betreiben.
Das,
klingt natürlich ziemlich abenteuerlich muss man wahrscheinlich so ein bisschen juristisch auch mal versuchen zumindest nachzuvollziehen weil natürlich kannst du so eine website nicht,
verbieten ne das können wir in deutschland nur unter nur dann wenn die webseite halt relativ klar.
Illegale tätigkeiten verfolgt oder darauf ausgerichtet ist natürlich werden in deutschland auch kriminelle webseiten irgendwie verboten und dann gibt's da irgendwie diese sperre tafeln drauf und so ne aber,
dieses war ja eine offene seite eine open posting seite das heißt die inhalte die dort stattfinden wann gleichzeitig nicht von denen die diese seite betrieben haben.
Ja
Wieder ist bei facebook ja auch ist.
Genau wie es bei facebook auch ist und weil sie aber jetzt natürlich diese webseite zu machen wollten ohne viel aufhebens haben sie sich entschieden naja wir verbieten.
Diese betreiber gruppierung als verein.
Selbstverständlich gab es aber jetzt nicht den links unten ev mit sitz in weiß nicht links unten der der zum zeit vereinszweck hatte diese seite zu betreiben,
aber es genügt jetzt viel mehr so die richtige die rechtliche argumentation wenn sich mehrere personen zusammenschließen.
Um sich einem gemeinsam gebildeten willen unterzuordnen,
und dass diese art von verein hätte es eben gegeben wenn sich menschen zusammentun um administratoren oder administratorin einer webseite zu sein die das ziel des postings verfolgt so.
Also ihr seid quasi verein per akklamation so wie ihr seid zwar rechtlich keiner aber für uns seid ihr es einfach mal trotzdem weil wir sehen und euch als solche.
Und das hat natürlich so blöd das klingt hat das natürlich seinen sinn dass man das grundsätzlich so tun kann weil sonst könntest du die mafia nicht verbieten die mafia hat ja auch keinen gibt ja keinen mafia ev,
und.
Ja oder oder so.
Genau die csu würdest du auch verbieten wollen ja.
Aber hat leider keine leistungsfähige adresse gehabt.
Hat keine handlungsfähige adresse pech gehabt ne also es ist schon verständlich warum,
der die gesetze quasi vorsehen dass du vereinigungen verbieten kannst gibt ja dann auch diese ganze paragraphen reihe hundertneunundzwanzig
a bis z was mitgliedschaft in einer kriminellen vereinigung kriminelle vereinigung ist eine eine vereinigung die quasi,
das ausführen von kriminellen taten als ihren zweck hat.
Und so weiter und so fort so jetzt haben die also gesagt okay wir verbieten den betreiberverein der links unten in die media betreibt,
und.
Jetzt gehen denen hängen für diese leute natürlich auch gleichzeitig strafverfahren wegen mitgliedschaft in einer kriminellen vereinigung an ja.
Die jetzt gerade mal definiert wurde.
Die jetzt gerade mal definiert wurde und jetzt haben die quasi vor dem.
Vor dem bundesverwaltungsgericht in leipzig dagegen geklagt und die kläger
drinnen waren in dem fall die beschuldigten diese webseite links unten betrieben zu haben und damit in einer kriminellen vereinigung sich engagiert zu haben,
und die argumentieren naja das ist.
Ein journalistisches medium und es gab ja auch eine moderation der beiträge und auch eine diskussion der beiträge und ist ja nicht so als wären dort unbedingt sämtliche rechts
die rechte von menschen verletzen den veröffentlichungen kritiklos hingenommen oder sogar ermutigt worden ganz das gegenteil.
Ist der fall deswegen hätte nach rundfunkstaatsvertrag zumindest zunächst die zuständige landesmedienanstalt gegen die beiträge vorgehen müssen und nicht gegen,
das medium oder in dem fall sogar die betreiber direkt zu einer kriminellen vereinigung zu zu machen so die argumentation der,
der von links unten die also sagen hier das was ihr hier mit uns gemacht habt entspricht nicht den medienrecht weil das handelt sich hier um ein medium und da müsst ihr,
gibt es diese ganzen sachen nach kenntnis abmahnungen pipapo rechtsverstoßes auflagen das könnt ihr alles mit uns machen aber ihr könnt nicht einfach sofort sagen ihr seid alle kriminell,
die ganze website muss weg mit ich glaube zweihunderttausend beiträgen von denen halt ein sehr sehr geringer prozentsatz eben,
problematisch war.
Genau und auch da.
Der war hätte man nochmal diskutieren müssen und hätten eben auch gerichte im im einzelfall der beiträge,
urteilen müssen all das wurde ja jetzt den beschuldigten verwehrt sondern wurde sofort gesagt zack,
guten tag tür knack auf dem boden verhaftet kriminell und so weiter ne computer weg auch darüber übrigens kongress vorträge ich glaube es war nicht nur einer,
so jetzt stehen die also in diesem bundesverwaltungsgericht in leipzig und sagen hier wir sind ein medium ihr könnt gegen uns nicht ihr könnt es nicht als verein einfach verbieten.
Und der die richter in leipzig sagen ja also sie klagen ja hier gegen das verbot einer vereinigung.
Wer von ihnen ist ein mitglied dieser vereinigung und die so.
An anderer stelle laufen gerade strafverfahren wenn wir jetzt hier sagen wir werden mitglied dieser vereinigung heißt es automatisch dass wir im strafverfahren über die mitgliedschaft in dieser vereinigung sofort und selber belasten.
Und dann sagt der richter na gut,
also gegen das verbot der vereinigung kann nur die vereinigung oder ein mitglied der vereinigung klagen ist hier mitglieds volk anwesend,
alles mit den füßen sich das weiß die klage ab und die können nach hause gehen.
Mit anderen worten die haben die haben das medium verboten als verein den verein gab es nicht die leute
können sich aber jetzt auch nicht beschuldigen mit gibt es wein zu sein weil sie dann sofort dafür bestraft worden wären mitglied des vereins zu sein und weil sie sagen sie sind nicht mitglied des vereins können sie aber nicht gegen das verbot des vereins klagen das heißt,
mit anderen worten aber dass sie nicht gegen das verbot des vereins klagen können sind sie quasi automatisch dran wegen mitgliedschaft in diesem verbotenen verein.
Das.
Ja
Kann so irgendwie nicht funktionieren.
Ich glaube das ist ein fall für karlsruhe.
Das wird auch nach karlsruhe wohl gehen ja denn die anwältin hat dann auch gesagt naja hier die de facto wird von den mutmaßlichen betreibern dieser webseite verlangt sich selber zu belasten.
Hallo.
Weil sie nur dann gegen das verbot klagen können wenn sie sich zu diesem verein bekennen und damit würden sie sich ja eben selbst belasten und,
die verpflichtung zur selbst belastung ist in der verfassung der bundesrepublik deutschland nicht vorgesehen deshalb.
Sieht sie also den weg jetzt nach karlsruhe im,
beim bundesverfassungsgericht und nicht am bundesverwaltungsgericht in leipzig das jetzt eben die klage abgewiesen hat und damit bleibt links unten erstmal verboten wohl gemerkt ohne
dass der inhalt der klage überhaupt diskutiert wurde diese ablehnung der klage ist aufgrund von von formalien
passiert eine formelle ablehnung.
Abweisungen der klage weil die eben nicht zu klage berechtigt sind solange sie sich nicht selber beschuldigen in diesem fall mitglied zu sein das ist schon sehr skurril und man muss jetzt mal überlegen.
Wie man das wenn man dieses vorgehen jetzt mal übersetzt in,
nehmen wir mal andere gruppierungen und das zeigt dann glaube ich auch warum hier dieser dieses vereins verbot eben eine perfide und eine falsche vorgehensweise ist gegen die betreiber einer open posting plattform diese gesetze würden ja,
halbwegs sinn ergeben wenn wir jetzt einfach mal links unten durch mafia oder nsu ersetzen.
Dafür sind die aber auch gedacht,
und da haben wir eben auch kriminelle vereinigung deren gründungszeit zweck das begehen von kriminellen taten ist und hier haben wir eine webseite medienrecht thematik und.
Da denke ich bin ich schon dabei zu sagen dass das mit sicherheit nicht.
Würden die nach medienrecht beurteilt werden mit ihrer webseite würden sie bei weitem nicht diese arten von strafen,
und diese art von vorgehen gegen sich sehen und das ist ja spezifisch das was hier durch diese durch dieses ummodeln zu einer.
Vereinigung oder zu einem verein passiert das denen nämlich komplett alles weggenommen wird was sie an medien medienrecht schutz für ihre website hätten
oder auch nur tele telemediendiensten kram ja die haben also quasi den wurden die rechte von die jedes facebook jedes twitter hätte jede website hätte die irgendwo in kommentarbereich anbietet
oder eine wikipedia hätte das wird ihnen alles genommen und das kann natürlich so kann so nicht sein dass es denke ich,
äußerst skurril und nicht nicht so wie das gesetz gedacht ist.
Da bin ich ja mal gespannt aber das sind so diese typischen fälle die vor karlsruhe meistens dann doch etwas zerbröseln.
Ja sowas landet dann zwar in karlsruhe aber auch jahre später ne das ist ja jetzt inzwischen dieses verbot ist jetzt mindestens anderthalb jahre her,
die webseite seitdem weg und es ist ja dann wirklich auch also man sieht an solchen verfahren.
Wie lange dann die beschuldigten damit beschäftigt sind sich gegen
diese vorwürfe zu werden strafrechtlich zivilrechtlich davor zu gehen die webseite ist seitdem platt beziehungsweise es wurde jetzt irgendwo wieder ein archiv davon veröffentlicht um
wenigstens die inhalte zu bewahren und wenn die jetzt nicht in der lage gewesen wären.
Mediales interesse für ihren fall
zu generieren aufrecht zu erhalten anwältinnen dafür zu begeistern sie irgendwie zu vertreten
dann geht sowas halt schnell mal einfach den bach runter ne da musst du halt wirklich einen langen atem und ein kampfeswillen haben um zu erkennen dass jetzt in diesem ganzen verbotsverfahren eben.
Wichtige werte auf dem spiel stehen,
für unsere demokratie und das hat nichts unbedingt damit zu tun ob einem jetzt jeder beitrag in der auf links unten gefällt oder nicht.
Deswegen ist das ein wichtiges verfahren.
So dann kommen wir mal darauf zu sprechen wie es den anderen journalisten so ergeht.
Ja tatsächlich also finde ich übrigens auch gut dass er nochmal kurz drauf anspricht weil dieses ganze links und ein ding zu den unterstützenden organisationen,
gehört
dann auch reporter ohne grenzen chaos computer club und eben die organisationen die jetzt vielleicht nicht unbedingt im rufe stehen vielleicht alle inhalte und veröffentlichungen dort.
Für unterstützenswert zu halten aber die eben die pressefreiheit für ein wichtiges gut halten die hier eben durchaus in gefahr steht.
Ebenfalls in gefahr steht die pressefreiheit in den usa wir haben ja schon und da gibt's jetzt,
das ist natürlich in dem kontext zu sehen aber auch andererseits nicht unbedingt wir haben ja schon über diesen hacking angriff auf jeff bezos gesprochen.
Eigner der washington post und kein journalist sondern einfach nur reichstag mensch des planeten.
Derzeit nach schätzung und im besitzer der new york times.
Der washington post.
Der washington post ja dass ich mal geshoppt.
Hat er sich geklickt auf amazon.
Ich war gerade im angebot ja man kann nur mutmaßen über seine seine motive das zu tun
aber soweit ich das bisher wahrgenommen habe scheint es so zu sein dass er
das zwar getan hat und dann auch mit seiner digital expertise der washington post dazu verhilft
sich da neu aufzustellen aber bisher weder hat durchscheinen lassen dass da irgendwie eine verquickung der amazon interessen also der unmittelbaren amazon interessen oder auch nur der berichterstattung darüber und der washington post stattgefunden hat einerseits oder dass er sich auch persönlich in irgendeiner form,
zu einer durchsetzung einer ihm geneigten politischen agenda genötigt gesehen hätte was natürlich etwas ist was,
ein donald trump nicht versteht so dementsprechend.
Nee.
Ist er seitdem quasi auch auf der liste seiner erzfeinde glaube ich ziemlich weit nach oben gerückt,
und deswegen ist ja auch diese ganze saudi-arabien connection in doppelt und dreifacher hinsicht wirklich super shady weil,
mittlerweile glaube ich vollkommen klar ist wie das trumps system funktioniert entweder du bist für ihn oder übers gegen ihn und er hatte halt so seine
autoritären buddies round the world ja ganz geil findet so dass erdogan und es sind irgendwie natürlich wladimir putin und es ist dann eben auch vor allem die saudi-arabische herrscher familie die er selten,
probleme hat mit dem klingelbeutel und da in der lage ist immer geld in irgendeine richtung zu setzen,
oder eben auch mal so aktionen durchzuziehen die sich andere so nicht trauen würde und man hat ja gesehen wie trump das ganze treiben der saudi-arabischen regierung,
gedeckt hat davon,
sind wir natürlich auch in europa und in deutschland auch nicht ganz frei wenn man sich mal so anschaut was so an waffenverkäufen da regelmäßig stattfindet und wie groß so die kritik.
Von saudi-arabien insgesamt so ist insbesondere wenn man die maßstäbe nimmt ihr an andere länder so angelegt werden,
das verhalt komischerweise dort immer enorm.
Ja das ist erstaunlich mit womit so manche durchkommen während.
Andere schon für kleinigkeiten ab.
Andere für die eine oder die müssen noch nicht mal massenvernichtungswaffen haben um ins erdloch gebombt zu werden also die.
Die doppelzüngigkeit und der.
Die heuchlerei im umgang mit den unterschiedlichen staaten und welche maßstäbe an sie gesetzt werden je nachdem wie viele öl oder geld sie haben ist schon sehr problematisch und,
wir haben über diesen in der letzten sendung gesprochen und durchaus kritisiert wie der technisch aufgearbeitet wurde.
Also sehr sehr dünn gleichzeitig wurde jetzt in dieser woche ein sehr ordentlicher.
Bericht eines hacking versuches,
veröffentlicht und zwar mal wieder von unseren freunden beim city lab city an der universität,
toronto ein labor unter ronald roberts die klassisch sehr viel staatstrojaner forschung machen so auch zu finden fischer so auch zu,
der nsu group dem,
israelischen unternehmen dass die schadsoftware pegasus als staatstrojaner vertreibt also ein direkter konkurrent von finn fischer würde man sagen.
So jetzt berichtet ein journalist der new york times und zwar mit namen ich dachte was ihr hundert mbit tim das,
nicht so schnell ben haben nichts.
Angeblich habe ich sogar zweihundertfünfzig.
Schön.
Der zweite.
Ja wunderbar dann ist weil dann hast du hier einen dicken torrent an.
Ja nur in die eine richtung halt du weißt ja wie das ist.
Okay also.
Jetzt will ich die ganze zeit ron hapert sagen das ist ben habe hat und ronald roberts der hat am
einundzwanzigsten juni eine textnachricht bekommen
die irgendwie den inhalt hatte ben hapert and the story of the body royal family mit einem link zu einer webseite news dreihundertfünfundsechzig dot com und es kam ihm natürlich etwas,
komisch vor und er hat nicht angeklickt sondern sich gesagt okay ich untersucht das erst mal was hier passiert ja.
Er hat bis dahin,
für fünf jahre für die new york times über saudi-arabien berichtet insbesondere mit fokus auf prinz mohammed also mbs mohammad bin-salman und der eben seit,
zweitausendfünf de facto der geschäftsführende monarch in saudi-arabien ist.
Jetzt hat er gesagt okay er sucht erstmal ob es überhaupt diese headline gibt gute idee und hat halt quasi
die angeblichen titel gegoogelt hat nichts gefunden dann hat er irgendwie den den herausgeber von der tatsächlichen website news gefragt ob sie eine domain,
dreihundertfünfundsechzig dot com unterhielten und er hat gesagt nein das tun wir nicht also na klar sieht hier klassisch nach einer fishing.
Domain aus und als er dann,
später das city einen bericht über den heck von oma abdulla sies veröffentlichte,
hat er den auch gelesen und gesehen dass dort die domain liebes dreihundertfünfundsechzig dot com als kommandant control server für die nsu pegasus malware angegeben war.
Und damit hat er dann
gesagt okay alles klar dann muss ich wohl mal mit diesen leuten reden hat den eben seinen seine textnachricht gezeigt und sind jetzt sagt also ja hier das ist relativ klar in diesem zeitraum wurde dieser server von,
pegasus verwendet wir haben insgesamt fünf,
personen identifiziert die davon angegriffen wurden zwischen mai und juni zwanzig achtzehn,
darunter irgendwie ein mitglied einer saudi-arabischen menschenrechtsorganisation
die in großbritannien natürlich den sitz hat es gibt nicht so etwas wie eine menschenrechtsorganisation in saudi-arabien das ist ungefähr so wie links unten kannst du nicht machen.
Dann mitglieder von amnesty international ein saudi-arabischen dissidenten der ein auf youtube irgendwie politische botschaften veröffentlicht und eben um abdul aziz,
so wie der in kanada glaube ich wohnt und eben jetzt hier ben hapert,
interessant ist dazu zu sagen dass,
dieser in den gleichen zeitraum fällt aber nach komplett anderen methoden funktioniert hat das heißt da.
Riecht es so ein bisschen danach dass.
Unter umständen diese sache vielleicht nochmal besser untersucht werden sollte am besten von den leuten weil die scheinen in meinen augen diejenigen zu sein die am meisten ahnung von.
Von pegasus bisher haben die,
das waren jetzt nur die angriffe die auf das saudi-arabische auf die auf saudi-arabien zurückgehen es gibt gleichermaßen auch darüber haben wir,
regelmäßig berichtet angriffe die gegen mexikanische präsidentinnen und journalistinnen geht.
Und das sieht alles relativ
fürchterlich aus was die gruppe dort macht n sagt natürlich so das waren wir nicht sagen auch sie könnten irgendwie us-amerikaner können sie gar nicht hacken weil sie telefonnummern gesperrt sind also alles sehr,
interessante komische geschichten und auch hier riecht es natürlich ein bisschen wieder nach.
Ja nach dass am ende irgendwelche briefkastenfirmen oder exporte restriktionen oder unterhändler oder unter unternehmen sich damit befassen.
Auf jeden fall ist saudi-arabien ganz weit vorne was den einsatz solcher,
trojaner und explore basierten techniken betrifft das scheint relativ offensichtlich zu sein überrascht auch herzlich wenig,
die große freude überhaupt ein überwachungsmaßnahmen insbesondere im mobilfunkbereich ist so ganzen arabischen emirate raum sehr groß gewesen schon immer.
Es gibt halt einen punkt dem wir den wir daraus an konsequenzen ziehen müssen es gibt nach meiner kenntnis wenn ich jetzt gerade keinen über sehr zwei.
Grundsätzlich ernstzunehmende hersteller von staatstrojanern das sind irgendwie n und finn fischer.
Und wenn nun die bundesrepublik deutschland sich in diesem bereich engagieren möchte,
dann hat sie eben hier offenbar die wahl von zwischen diesen beiden unternehmen,
die beide gleichermaßen in sehr sehr bedenkliche menschenrechtsverletzungen und angriff strategien,
der mit saudi-arabischen oder türkischem oder jan mariechen ursprung verwickelt sind,
und das bedeutet natürlich auch wenn jetzt deutschland kunde solche unternehmen ist dass damit diese unternehmen irgendwie
ja gewürdigt werden statt statt geächtet zu werden und auch unser geld erhalten statt unseren entschiedenen
unsere entschiedene gegenwehr gegen das was sie tun oder gegen die menschen mit denen sie hier offenbar handel betreiben und das ist das,
das zeigt hier auch dass das deutsche dass das dilemma der europäischen unternehmen,
und und starten das ist so dreckig.
Die ist nicht so schön es hat nicht.
Patrick breyer hier.
Pirat.
Genau bekannt als pirat,
und acker vorrat hat schon damals gegen die vorratsdatenspeicherung geklagt sitzt jetzt im eu-parlament und kämpft,
fleißig weiter für den datenschutz und der hat jetzt geklagt vor dem europäischen gerichtshof.
Gegen und zwar den menschen rechtsgerichtete gegen die,
generelle und unterschiedslos e zwangs identifizierung aller nutzerinnen von mobiltelefonen,
smartphones will mal kurz erklären wie der der kontext ist es gibt in deutschland eine regelung im telekommunikationsgeschäft schon.
Damals unter bundeswirtschaftsminister wolfgang clement entworfen und der stand dort stark unter einfluss von spd bundesinnenminister chili,
können wir auch froh sein dass wir denen nicht mehr haben was nicht heißt dass seehofer unbedingt besser wäre.
Da irgendein anderer innenminister sich.
Innenminister ist immer schwierig.
Ist immer schwierig da wirst du einfach irgendwie bekloppt.
Aber chili auch so ein leuchtendes leuchtendes deutsches gestellt hier vom raps anwalt zum innenminister.
Er wird uns immer mit diesem wunderschönen foto in erinnerung bleiben weil diesen polizeiknüppel in der hand hat.
Chili.
Ja traumhaft das ist eigentlich echt das einzige bild was er von dem noch im kopf hat und so ein paar schwarz-weiß bilder wie er da irgendwie frech ist bei der.
Aber ist ein schönes symbolbild für diese haut drauf mentalität so ne wenn du da irgendwie was hast du in minister haut einfach erstmal drauf so wir hauen einfach so lange drauf bis irgendwas kaputt geht es wird schon irgendwie helfen.
Naja genau dieses gesetz wurde zweitausendvier verabschiedet mit den stimmen von spd grünen cdu nur die fdp hat dagegen gestimmt.
Und in diesem telekommunikations gesetz wurde festgelegt für jeden anschluss den ihr irgendeine hat muss klar sein wer den hat und dann wurde das.
Zuletzt in der von der großen koalition quasi verhärtet,
wo gesagt wurde ja und hier mit diesen sim-karten und zone da wollen wir übrigens jetzt auch dass jeder jeder prozess einer solchen sim-karten kaufst mit einem vorliegen eines personalausweises verbunden wird.
Das ist in deutschland der fall,
in vielen anderen ländern aber auch nicht wenn's in österreich haben wir es auch versprochen aber zum beispiel in den niederlanden oder in dänemark kannst du dir eine prepaid sind kaufen fertig,
und kannst dir einfach benutzen so.
Die eu-kommission hat zweitausendelf diskutiert ob man so ein identifizierung zwang in europa einführt aber hat gesagt die eu-kommission hat gesagt es gibt kein nachweis dass das in irgendeiner form wirksam wäre,
was die einzelstaaten hier bisher gemacht haben deswegen machen wir das nicht.
So patrick beyer patrick breyer argumentiert der identifizierung zwang erschwert ist technisch unbedarften bürgern unzumutbar
ohne furcht vor nachteilen zum beispiel telefonische beratung oder hilfe in anspruch zu nehmen straftaten anzuzeigen pressesprecher über missstände in kenntnis zu setzen das kann mitunter soweit gehen dass es menschenleben kostet zum beispiel wenn sich straftäter aus furcht vor verfolgung nicht mehr anonym,
irgendwohin wenden können.
Auf der straße und per post kann man kommunizieren ohne namen und geburtsdatum nennen zu müssen und personalausweis zu zeigen per telefon über über oder das internet darf das nicht,
anders sein,
jetzt hat aber leider der europäische gerichtshof der europäische menschenrechts gerichtshof entschieden dass die generelle und unterschied lose zwangs identifizierung aller nutzer von mobiltelefon und smartphones zulässig,
ist das ist ärgerlich.
Sie können nun gegen das urteil eine überprüfung durch die große kammer des eugh beantragen und sie werden jetzt prüfen anhand der begründung.
Ob sie da noch eine aussicht sehen und ob sie diese möglichkeit in angriff nehmen oder nicht aber bis auf weiteres bleibt uns also die registrierungspflicht,
erhalten.
Tja das ist ärgerlich.
Ich habe hier gerade mal so 'ne karte aufgerufen wie es eigentlich in europa gerade so aussieht wenn ich das richtig interpretiere hast du keine registrierungspflicht derzeit in,
kroatien in tschechien in rumänien portugal.
Ok interessanterweise irland island schweden finnland estland lettland dänemark.
Ja und so kann europa und so weiter scheint mir angst zu haben.
Ja
Aber auch norwegen.
Es gibt aber auch jetzt keine unterschiede weil wer jetzt als krimineller mobiltelefon braucht ne findet ja trotzdem seine wege ja es ist ja so dass du.
Ja die gehen dann irgendein laden ich meine es sind dann irgendwelche.
Geht's halt auf dem flohmarkt und holst dein handy ist eine karte drin fertig.
Ja und ich meine es gibt auch genug shady handy läden die
ich meine das sind dann sozusagen diese leute da mit diesem niedrigen margen die letzten endes check pflicht durchsetzen sollen die daran eigentlich gar kein interesse haben die wollen irgendwie verkaufen so und
am ende behaupten sie halt einfach das war so.
Der späti betreiber hat einfach echt ein super schlechten track record im verlieren seiner telefone,
und er erbärmlich dass jetzt eben leute diese sim-karten gefunden und weiter benutzt haben aber er hat ja keinen schaden dadurch ne das heißt also es ist nach wie vor problemlos möglich eine anonyme sim-karte zu bekommen oder eine anders benannte sim-karte zu bekommen wenn man eine haben möchte
es ist aber eben für die ganzen
normalen unbescholtenen bürgerinnen eben eine überwachungsmaßnahmen die wirkt ähnlich übrigens wie diese gesichts überwachung gesichter fassung wo der oder diejenige die nicht erkannt werden wollen sich einfach mal den mantel ein bisschen höher ins gesicht ziehen können oder mit einem regenschirm durch die gegend rennen während alle anderen
hier eben einer vollständigen überwachung unterliegen,
tja so ist das mit den massenüberwachung maßnahmen die einfach zu umgehen sind.
Kommen wir zu den kurzmeldungen.
Man.
Am fünfundzwanzigsten september zwanzigachtzehn wurde beim kammergericht berlin,
festgestellt dass da verbindungen zu einem wohlbekannten command and control server ausgehen sodass also
kommando confort server du hast wenn du jetzt irgendwie eine jemanden mit schadsoftware infiziert brauchst du irgendein
kanal zurück das ist dein kommando kontrolle server je nachdem wie elegant du das machst hast du eben irgendwo im internet irgendeinen server stehen der erstmal aussieht wie irgendeine webseite
und wenn sich deine infizierten geräte dort melden und dort verbindungen
in herstellen dann übertragen sie schön über gps irgendwelche daten dorthin du kannst ihn befehle geben sagen mach mal hier bitte folgendes machen wir ein podcast knack mal den zugang oder so ne,
klassisch,
schadsoftware die nicht vollständig im blindflug agiert braucht einen command in control kanal jetzt wurde also beim kammergericht berlin festgestellt dass es dort.
Dass dort kommando controll kommunikation stattfindet mit anderen worten dass es irgendwo,
geräte geben muss die infiziert sind also hat man sich überlegt wen könnten wir fragen der sich damit auskennt nehmen wir doch,
systems systems ist gekommen hat dann irgendwie ein gutachten veröffentlicht das gutachten oder aber also den angefertigt das gutachten wurde aber irgendwie nie so wirklich veröffentlicht und jetzt,
hatte das ursprünglich den titel dass dort ein befall mit e-motor,
festgestellt worden war über haben wir schon mal in einer folge relativ lange gesprochen und haben uns spezifisch eher auf die aktuell grassierenden wellen mit renzo konzentriert.
Grundsätzlich ist die gang aber nicht nur in einem geschäftsfeld tätig sondern die machen auch,
also sind ebenso in verbindung mit banking angriffen oder eben auch spionage je nachdem was sich eben lohnt und,
jetzt hat sich hier weiterhin ergeben dass also
erstens ist es das sein schwerwiegender fall einer emotion info infektion mit nicht abzuschätzen den folgen für das netzwerk die system und die daten des kammergerichts und dann wurde weiter untersucht und.
Jetzt mussten sie irgendwie zähneknirschend zugestehen dass sie erstens nicht wissen wie es zu dieser eingestehen dass sie erstens nicht wissen wie es zu dieser infektion kam
also sie haben jetzt keine e-mail gefunden mit irgendeinem anhang oder so sie konnten nicht identifizieren wer jetzt patient null ist unter den rechnern.
Und außerdem sagen sie naja dass hier daten abgeflossen sind können wir nicht ausschließen denn,
es gibt hier offenbar schadsoftware die installiert wurde,
die eindeutig auf datenabfragen ausgerichtet ist es steht aber wiederum nicht da drin ob das auch passiert ist.
Also.
Mal also ähnlich schlecht wie dieses diese untersuchung wo gesagt wurde sind daten abgeflossen die können aber nicht sagen wie und welche,
sondern einfach nur der dinger daten eingeladen hier sagen sie naja es gibt eine schadsoftware die sieht aus als könnte sie daten abfließen lassen wir wissen aber nicht ob es tatsächlich passiert ist.
Also schwierig jetzt
warum ist das problematisch für so einen kammergericht naja da in den daten die die haben befinden sich irgendwie vielleicht hinweise auf verdeckte ermittler informanten zeugin irgendwelche terror prozesse oder sonstiges.
All die ganzen ermittlungsakten gegen irgendwelche gruppen mafiösen strukturen etcetera und wenn da irgendwie jetzt der der russe dieser daten habhaft geworden ist könnte ich mir durchaus vorstellen dass es gerade im berliner raum durchaus
interesse geben könnte an diesen informationen.
Also das sieht das sieht nicht gut aus gleichzeitig in dem bericht eine ganze reihe an katastrophalen,
verfehlungen ne die haben da irgendwie ein flaches netzwerk unterhalten ohne irgendwelche ohne irgendwelche reparationen in den in den netzwerken.
Bisher einmal drin bist du überall.
Ja so wie bei dir zu hause alles in einem sack nur dass es halt ein gericht ist ja katastrophe.
Das.
Es ist es ist so müßig da auch mal wieder drauf rumzuhacken aber das das ist halt einfach erst.
Jahrelang an dass man den scheiß alles ja nicht braucht dann kommt so dieser druck oh gott jetzt brauchen wir den scheiß ja doch,
dann fehlt dir einfach die erfahrung und dann fehlt dir einfach so der der umgang damit und so das bewusstsein,
wie man es denn dann machen soll und dann unterliegt das alles diesen zwängen und wenig geld und irgendwie kriegen wir das schon hin und wieso was wollt ihr denn eigentlich läuft doch.
Und dann fällt die bombe und meine ist ja hier auf zwei ebenen wirklich dramatisch erstens das jetzt einfach dieses kammergericht rein technisch einfach in ermangelung ihrer arbeitsmittel nicht mehr richtig arbeiten kann,
und das für,
erstaunlich lange zeiträume da hängt ja einfach eine menge dran weil die entscheiden ja über recht ja leute fristen laufen ab leute können ihr gerecht nicht wahrnehmen,
das ist das eine und das andere was wir eben schon angesprochen haben in dem moment wo halt hier auch wirklich eine spionage stattgefunden hat in irgendeiner form
kannst du einfach dazu führen dass einfach viele fälle dann einfach auch überhaupt nicht mehr durch furchtbar sind weil informationen öffentlich liegen oder schlicht und ergreifend
so viele gruppen jetzt vorgewarnt sind dass da was gegen sie läuft dass die halt ihre operationen entsprechend tarnen decken zu machen umziehen sonst wie schützen etcetera also
total schaden ist hier schon wirklich die richtige bezeichnung aber ich würde halt noch weitergehen als it totalschaden,
das ist ein total schade.
Es ist ein klassisch ist aber es ist auch ein klassiker ne weil ich kann ja also
heise zitiert so ein bisschen aus dem aus dem bericht ne dass ein angreifer höchstwahrscheinlich in der lage gewesen ist den gesamten datenbestand des gerichts zu exportieren und zu manipulieren und jetzt kommt's ne
die tatsache dass das event looks fehlen legt darüber hinaus nahe dass auch ein zugriff durch dritte von externen erfolgt ist
bei ihrer analyse des vorfalls machen die experten gleich reihenweise schwachpunkte in der it-infrastruktur aus und jetzt kommt dazu zählen das versagen der point protection lösung von mac
die nämlich eigentlich schon signaturen für diese schatz auf der gehabt hätte haben müssen gesollt.
Fehlende filter und netzwerk segmentieren lokale administratoren rechte und mangelnde lok dateien diese schwächen ermöglichen es dass aus einem standard vorfall ein massiver instant wurde,
da sich kaum herausfinden lasse welche systeme tatsächlich infiziert wurden bleibt lediglich letztlich nur die gesamte windows domäne neu aufzuziehen dabei könne das kammerich die aktuelle situation nutzen ein leistungsfähiges und sicheres neues netzwerk zu konstruieren und den schaden bei zu fängst
zufälligen vorfällen stark zu begrenzen und da sage ich dir eins dieser teil am ende mit,
wie ein scanner hat nicht funktioniert ihr habt keine looks ihr habt das netz nächste sieg regiert.
Dekretiert.
Ventil,
und ihr könnt es jetzt neu bauen und einmal richtig dann habt ihr wenigstens was davon der teil ja der stand schon im template den habe ich nämlich auch,
in meinen berichten zu solchen fällen den schreibst du nicht neu den kannst du eigentlich am ende jedem,
geben den für den teil war es kein tagessatz zu berechnen den hast du schon fertig,
weil das überall so ist und wenn die wenn das kammergericht da sein netzwerk betreibt wie uschis nagelstudio dann müssen sie sich auch nicht wundern wenn sie am ende geordnet werden.
So ist es.
Nagelstudio sind jetzt auch in gefahr.
Ich wollte nur sagen nagelstudios haben halt kein besonders hohe schutzbedarf weil die keine ne die sind nicht so abhängig die haben.
Würde ich wohl meinen.
Ja die müssen ja ein bisschen bezahlen so ne bis.
Vielleicht.
Pumpfläschchen mitgehen.
Ich hätte gerne auch noch einen bogen dazu.
So entspannt hier bei der maniküre.
Hallo.
So kommen wir jetzt zur nächsten ernsten thema.
Wir sind so seriös ist super.
Russland.
Schon wieder gibt's noch was anderes mann mann mann die haben sich aber auch echt den newsticker hoch hochgeschoben ist echt zum heulen.
Tja jetzt hat die russische aufsichtsbehörde roskomnadzor.
Ach so tolle abkürzung.
Das ist doch niemand abkürzen glaube ich die haben.
Gesagt wir möchten jetzt den zugang zu mailbox dot org in russland sperren und,
mailbox ist ein email-anbieter ich glaube einer von denen die sich mühe geben den service sicher zu betreiben und glaube ich auch den leuten geld dafür abzunehmen wenn sie diesen dienst nutzen also erstmal genau richtig.
Ich glaube die sind so gibt's ja eine reihe ne es gibt irgendwie posterio proton mail mailbox org wo wo man sich bemüht eine e-mail service,
ernsthaft datenschutzberater zu betreiben.
Kurzer hinweis also natürlich ist roskomnadzor eine abkürzung voll ausgeschrieben auf deutsch heißt das föderale dienst für die aufsicht im bereich der kommunikation informationstechnologie und massen kommunikation.
Kannst du das auch nochmal auf russisch sagen bitte.
Nein das steht zwar hier aber ich bin des russischen nicht auch nur im entfernten mächtig komme aus dem westen du ja auch.
Ja
Ich könnte das jetzt hier bestenfalls von irgendeinem tool vorlesen lassen aber ich glaube das willst du nicht vielleicht links geil.
Jedenfalls die verlangen von mailbox org dass sie sich in ein ein verzeichnis der russischen telekommunikationsanbieter eintragen müssten.
Weil ihr dienst ja schließlich aus russland
erreichbar und aufrufbar ist mailbox org sagt jetzt sehen wir anders weil wir haben keine russischsprachige website wir haben keine it-systeme in russland wir haben keinen wir sprechen russische kundenkreis e nicht spezifisch an deswegen sehen wir keine verpflichtung uns hier,
bei
der beim föderalen dienst für die aufsicht im bereich der kommunikation informationstechnologie und markenkommunikation zu registrieren vermutlich würden ja auch mit dieser registrierung entsprechende auflagen was zugriff und so weiter,
angeht einhergehen.
Also wurde die sperre vor gericht beantragt und das wird dann jetzt wohl auch passieren,
ja es wird ein gerichtsprozess stattfinden wenn es zu einer sperre kommt weiß man eben auch nicht was das was das eben,
für folgen hat ob man dann zum beispiel da noch e-mails hinschicken kann oder nicht,
oder ob man als russischer community quasi komplette russische kommunikation zu diesem mailserver auch unterbunden wird gleichzeitig haben sie dann,
gesagt okay wir bauen schon mal einen hinten service auf damit unsere russischen kunden in zukunft weiterhin darauf zugreifen können und es ist.
Nicht so als würden wir es nur mit mit mailbox org machen sondern sie haben es kürzlich auch schon mit protonen mehl gemacht dem,
schweizerischen e-mails service.
Aber zugreifbar keit auf über tor weil glaube ich bei mailbox ort ohnehin schon.
Das kann sein dass ihr es schon hatten ja sorry sie machen's ein bewerbens natürlich jetzt nur noch mehr und proton mail ist,
offenbar also die sind schon auf dem modus dass sie sagen hier wir sind teilweise blockiert in russland das haben sie gestern bekannt gegeben und sagen es gibt
teilweise offenbar blockaden deswegen greift bitte auf unsere webseite über den tor browser zu dass bei proton mail insofern,
wahrscheinlich noch die geringere beeinträchtigung weil die tatsächlich überhaupt keine app oder so anbieten die haben nur den zugriff über die app und über.
Über ein interface sodass,
das im prinzip für die meisten also wenn man einmal proton mail haben möchte muss man dafür bezahlen und sich in so eine bridge aufbauen das heißt wahrscheinlich haben die meisten,
nutzerinnen und nutzer ohnehin zugriff nur über den webbrowser und dann müssen sie sich jetzt hier nur einen anderen.
Ein anderen browser benutzen können natürlich auch einfach muss ja noch nicht mal über den hidden service sein in dem moment wo dein tor browser benutzt um gehst ja ohnehin zensuren.
Ja also dass die befürchtung die man jetzt hier also über russland hatte dass diese wir machen net,
scheint sich hier dann auch entsprechend zu bewahrheiten.
So hatten wir noch irgendein dauerthema noch nicht wieder auf dem tisch.
Das bundespolizei setz das ist jetzt wirklich unterhaltsam seehofer mit seinen polizeigesetzen kommt raus,
auf dem menü für das bundespolizei gesetz steht die bundespolizei polizei soll hack back machen wird berichtet,
anna sally hat das glaube ich als erstes berichtet relativ ausführlich die seehofer will den digitalen gegen andere staaten war der titel des berichtes veröffentlicht am neunundzwanzigsten januar ja update,
fünf um am gleichen tag ja um fünfzehn uhr neunundfünfzig.
Ein sprecher des bmi teilt uns gegenüber mit in dem aktuellen ressort verfahren befinden,
in dem aktuell im resort verfahren befindlichen gesetzesvorschlag ist eine solche regelung nicht enthalten patrick beuth hatte paar minuten vorher seine antwort bekommen das heißt es jetzt schon wieder vom tisch also wieder eine berichterstattung.
Über ein zu diskutieren das thema und es ist sofort,
offenbar dann doch wieder aus dem polizeigesetz raus also seehofer will gerade sein polizeigesetz da endlich durchkriegen und es ist eigentlich scheint sich jetzt quasi.
Die strategie zu sein so viel wie möglich davon an problematischen dingen.
Jetzt einfach mal zu berichten weil er gerade mal so unter druck ist dass er dann sofort abschneidet.
Aber es ist so so unterhaltsam das jetzt klingen mag oder so schön muss man dazu einfach sagen.
Da wird ein gesetz vorangetrieben und wir haben jetzt irgendwie berichterstattung über die inhalte dieses gesetzes und jedes mal wenn darüber berichtet wird sagen stimmt ja gar nicht,
was ist das für eine demokratie,
also diese gesetzgebungsverfahren schockieren mich immer und immer wieder ja wie also hier die regierung ihre gesetzes ihre gesetzgebungsverfahren im versteckten held,
dann wenn darüber berichtet wird dann kann das nur wieder aus irgendwelchen leaks kommen und dann dementieren sie das beim beim it-sicherheitsgesetz haben wir seit monaten nichts mehr gehört seitdem ist da mal diesen referentenentwurf gab und.
Wo findet hier noch diese diskussion statt.
Wo findet hier noch die inhaltliche auseinandersetzung statt ich bin ja eh schon abgefressen seitdem irgendwie letzte mal diese staatstrojaner gesetzgebung wo auch wieder irgendwie aus dem
allerletzten freitagnachmittag irgendwie die einladung kam
als sachverständiger dort aufzutreten ich glaube am montag war die verhandlung oder sowas ja niemand hatte das gesetz gesehen,
mir fällt gerade nicht mehr ein welches gesetz das war wo die sachverständigen in dem ausschuss auftraten,
und ihnen gesagt wurde achso übrigens das wozu ihr jetzt eure stellungnahmen geschrieben habt der ist ja gar nicht mehr aktuell aber ja braucht er gar nicht mehr zu reden und die sachverständigen sagt ja was ist denn das aktuelle damit wir da jetzt darüber reden können ich hab da noch nicht.
So
Scheiße gelaufen.
Schicken wir euch schenken wir euch mit der post dann nächste woche so ne also das so sind diese gesetzgebungsprozess wirklich
nicht gedacht und jedes mal wenn ich irgendwie wenn so etwas passiert stirbt irgendwo ein kleines demokratie kätzchen und das ist wirklich unschön,
das so zu machen das ist wirklich eine tja.
Ein angriff auf die demokratie um da mal den den schulzzug zu bemühen.
So ist das nicht gedacht dass gesetze bei uns passieren es ist nicht so gedacht dass hier irgendein horst durch durch
durch regiert und dass die die entstehung der gesetze möglichst lange im dunkeln gehalten wird bis dann irgendwann mal,
versucht wird die öffentliche diskussion darüber möglichst klein zu halten das ist ja erklärtes ziel von horst seehofer und auch von anderen politikern und politikerinnen an in dieser regierung zu sagen,
boah wie können wir hier wie können wir hier noch gesetze machen ohne dass sie sich sich da draußen darüber aufregen.
Und das ist ein sorry das ist nicht die idee die idee ist dass sich die leute da draußen darüber aufregen und dass dein einer gesellschaftlichen konsens herbeigeführt wird und nicht dass irgendein seehofer sagt boah wie kann man jetzt mal ich muss jetzt mal langsam liefern,
und die die da draußen geben ja offen sack das ist nicht das das ist nicht die idee.
Ja man,
ich weiß jetzt nicht ich will jetzt nicht zu verschwörungstheoretiker jetzt hier rangehen aber mir kommt es auch oft manchmal so vor dass das auch alles so.
So zwiebelschalen sind um den kern
nicht zu gefährden ja also der bundespolizei gesetz polizeigesetze an sich in den letzten jahren
sind hoch problematisch weil sie einfach den rahmen dessen wozu die polizei.
Was die was die polizei an maßnahmen ergreifen kann dieser rahmen wird immer weiter ausgedehnt nicht wir hatten ja auf länderebene jetzt über jahre schon diese ganze auseinandersetzung und es ist absehbar dass es eben jetzt auf bundespolizei ähnlich läuft,
wenn man jetzt solche vorschläge macht und dann eben sozusagen so ein kern durchbringen will dann ist es ja ganz praktisch,
wenn man auch noch ein paar total out rajes sachen auch noch einfach mit obendrauf packt weil sich natürlich die öffentlichkeit
in dem moment wo sie sich überhaupt damit beschäftigt erstmal mit dem scheiß auseinandersetzt der so überhaupt nicht geht so ja was weiß ich nur noch leute
in grüner kleidung werden sind gestartet aber auch nur dienstags und so weiter da spinnt sich dann eine wochenlange diskussionen darüber da wird es irgendwann zurückgenommen und man hat vollkommen übersehen was da drunter in den inneren zwiebelschalen
eigentlich im kern mit drin ist von daher ja empörung.
So eine sollbruchstelle direkt mit einbauen.
Genau also einfach so ja egal die zwiebelschalen die machen wir dann einfach ab jetzt doch alles gut so.
Und dann dann können wir da kriegen wir zu kreuze und sagen ja hier,
nach protesten hat horst seehofer des racial profiling aus der novelle der strafprozessordnung gestrichen ja da wird das schön auf tagesschau de berichtet,
und dann ist gut.
Wir hören ja auch auf die gesellschaft und wir sind ja da auch im ständigen dialog und immer bereit zum kompromiss heißt es dann in der pressemitteilung.
Wir haben wir haben verstanden.
Wir haben verstanden.
Es katastrophal das so politik gemacht wird und es ist eine ist wirklich,
ganz schlimm und schlecht dass das dass es so passiert ja da kommen viele faktoren zusammen da können wir jetzt stundenlang darüber reden natürlich auch die
gekürzten aufmerksamkeitsspanne mit den menschen sich heute noch mit themen auseinandersetzen diese,
aufregern bei die hier auch eine sachliche auseinandersetzung,
ja verhindert und die aber gleichzeitig natürlich durch dieses informationen zurückhaltend dann mal kurz drauf kübeln auch sehr genau genutzt werden kann also jedes mal müssen wir auch sehen jedes mal wenn die sagen.
Hier gesichtserkennung protest war weg hier hack back protestwahl weg führen sie ja auch diejenigen die sich quasi,
alarmiert werden durch solche kurzfristigen mitteilungen und unmittelbar bevorstehenden gesetzes,
umgebungsverhältnissen führen sie ja auch den die zivilgesellschaft vor die sich hier bemüht,
den gesetzgebungsprozess zu begleiten und zu darauf hinzuwirken dass er ordentlich ist ne und wenn dann irgendwie etwas in anbetracht der der der zeitlichen drucks kanalisiert,
oder laut berichtet werden muss dann könnte sich ja nachher wieder zurücklegen und sagen ja ja die schreien ja immer nur rum sind ja gar nicht die haben ja gar keine ahnung was wir hier machen genau das ist nicht der das ist nicht das wie es gedacht ist.
So kleiner test wie heißt unsere bundesjustizministerin.
Nordhäuser barley.
Wir haben eine neue lamprecht.
Ja genau.
Lampsdorf.
Christine lamprecht dass unsere bundesjustizministerin seit juni neunzehn und es ist so ein name wo ich dann auch erstmal so ein bisschen nach hinten kippe mir denke so ach echt.
Gar nicht mitbekommen,
zur erinnerung frau katarina barley die er da auf diesem posten gesetzt wurde mit großem trara und großer feierei wo er dann im rahmen der europawahl der letzten dann auch gleich wieder abgeworben und ist mittlerweile vizepräsident im europaparlament
und deswegen ist sie weg und muss halt nach bestückt werden das wird natürlich dann,
parteiintern geregelt so die merkel als kanzlerin nichts dagegen hat
und ja dann fiel die wahl auf christine lamprecht und die ist halt nicht nur justizministerin sondern,
muss ich natürlich auch auch um verbraucher schutz kümmern denn das ist ja seinerzeit mal,
beim umweltministerin gelandet und mittlerweile gewechselt zum.
Nie gesehen.
Justizministerin das ministerium genau und deswegen war halt die frage ob es sich hierbei um eine gute nachricht handelt.
Schauen wir mal.
Aux
Denn die bundesjustizministerin hat einen referentenentwurf vorgelegt der sich so aufs vertragsrecht im allgemeinen und gerade was so,
mobilfunkverträge und fern verträge betrifft sich darauf bezieht.
Und es könnte sich unter anderem auch auf die vertragslaufzeiten auswirken die,
derzeit so für mobilfunk und sonstige internet verträge gelten wer selber schon mal versucht hat mobilfunkvertrag abzuschließen das sind glaube ich so ziemlich.
Also den den vertrag abzuschließen ist einfach.
Die loszuwerden.
Ja genau aber sich auch nur ein kopf darüber zu machen was sind wohl jetzt der richtige modus wäre es schwierig und irgendwann kommt dann dieser punkt so
ja sieht geil aus aber hält halt zwei jahre das ist so eigentlich das übliche vierundzwanzig monate dauern verträge.
Gab es auch schon mal in länger.
Und hier ist also jetzt geplant oder zumindest besagt dass ist erstmal dieser entwurf das ist ja erstmal soweit noch gar nichts hier ein limit einzuziehen der zumindest die laufzeit dieser verträge auf ein jahr begrenzen würde,
und außerdem auch noch eine üblicherweise dann auch noch sich selbst aktivierende zeitbombe einer verlängerung,
wo dann der vertrag schnell mal noch ein jahr ist wenn man nicht rechtzeitig kündigt so automatische verlängerung bei einer laufzeit zu limitieren auf ich glaube drei monate.
Drei monate.
Ja also die dann die verlängerung sozusagen also wenn du
wenn er sich verlängert verlängert er sich macht um maximal ein vierteljahr und nicht um nochmal ein ganzes jahr.
Also das zumindest der entwurf ob das jetzt so durchkommt muss man mal sehen mein bauchgefühl sagt mir
die zeit ist eigentlich reif für solche maßnahmen stinkt den leuten und wir wissen alle dass die dynamik auf dem mobilfunkmarkt insbesondere
oder generell im internet markt in deutschland einfach so scheiße ist und natürlich auch durch diese zwei jahren enorm eingeschränkt wird weil
es gibt natürlich wie heißt es immer so schön planungssicherheit ja wir wissen wir können jetzt irgendwie die scheiß tarife noch eine weile durchhalten weil sehr viele leute eben dann noch zwei jahre daran rumhängen
und komischerweise tut sich ja dann auch immer irgendwie in so einem zwei jahren oder gewisse jahresraten muss aber eben relativ selten tut sich dann immer mal wieder irgendwie was
und das könnte dadurch natürlich besser werden.
Ja und das wäre das wäre natürlich die hoffnung weil.
Die dadurch dass die kundinnen und kunden irgendwie mobiler würden in ihren mobilfunkverträge sich diese zyklen und der konkurrenzdruck einfach erhöhen würde de facto hast du nämlich.
Keine also die die konkurrenz auf diesem markt ist enorm geschwächt dadurch dass die leute so ekelhaft lange an ihre verträge gebunden sind dass sie vergessen dass sie da noch drin sind wenn du dann sagst ach jetzt habe ich das ding nochmal zwei jahre an der backe,
und man nachfragt sagen ja kennen sie den satz,
kündigungsfrist ist drei monate zum ende der vertragslaufzeit ihr vertrag hat sich gerade um ein jahr verlängert und das ist alles sehr,
dass solche mechanismen führen dazu dass sich die preis der preisdruck nicht so wirklich auswirkt und die sehr sehr behäbig konkurrenz konkurrieren und sich eben deswegen auch so behäbig hohe preise halten können,
weil der das risiko dass jemand sein mobilfunkvertrag wechselt einfach kaum gegeben ist.
Insofern würden wir hier der guten frau wie heißt der nochmal lamprecht glückwünschen mit ihrem vorstoß.
Nicht nur das auch können sie auch ruhig beschleunigen verträge laufen demnächst aus,
das finde ich dann doch mal ganz gut fein das bringt uns jetzt ans ende der sendung.
Ja und da muss ich noch mal danken und zwar daniel dem gleichen daniel wie du letzte mal.
Daniel ja okay.
Herzlichen dank ja sorry nochmal dass du die ganzen folgen nachhören musstest aber für uns hat sich's gelohnt.
Jut.
Ja damit was das was das an die schöne nachrichten.
Das war's schon ja genau.
Ja damit zurück ins internet.
Entlassen wir euch bis dann tschau tschau.
Tschau tschau.